this video is about the kaplan-meier
curve we'll go through what the
kaplan-meier curve is and how you can
create it the formulas used are from the
very recommendable book survival
analysis by david g kleinbaum and
mitchell klein
and we get started right away
the kaplan-meier curve is used to
graphically represent the survival rate
or survival function
here the time is plotted on the x-axis
and the survival rate on the y-axis but
what is the survival rate
let's say you are a dental technician
and you want to study the survival time
of a filling in a tooth
so your start time is the moment when a
person gets a feeling at the dentist
and the end time the event is the moment
when this filling breaks out
you're interested now in the time
between these two situations
in the kaplan-meier curve you can see
how likely it is that a filling will
last longer than a certain time
for example you might be interested in
the probability that your filling will
last longer than let's say 5 years
in order to do this simply read off the
value at 5 years to see how high the
survival rate is
at 5 years the kaplan-meier curve gives
you a value of
0.7
it is therefore 70
likely that a filling will last longer
than 5 years
therefore the survival time curve tells
you how likely it is that the person
survives a certain point in time
this leads us to the question how you
can create a kaplan-meier curve based on
your own data
here i will show you how you can easily
create the kaplan-meier curve online
with data tab and then we'll go through
how you can calculate the required
tables by hand and how you can draw the
kaplan-meier curve using these tables
in order to create the kaplan-meier
curve with data tab simply visit
datadab.net and copy your own data into
this table
now you click on plus and select
survival analysis
if you now select the variable time
data tab creates the kaplan-meier curve
and here below you see the survival
table
if you don't click on a status datadeb
assumes that none of the data is
censored if this is not the case you
need to click on the variable that
contains the information which case is
censored and which is not
1 stands for event occurred and 0 stands
for censored
now you get the appropriate results for
this down here
if you had factors where you wanted to
check if they have an influence on the
curve
you click on them here and the log rank
test or the cox regression would be
calculated for you
but now i will show you how to create
this table and the curve yourself
to create a kaplan kaplan-meier curve
you first need the data of your test
patients
let's say the feeling lasted three years
for the first test person
four years for the second
four years for the third and so on and
so forth of course the data are purely
fictitious now
let us first assume that none of the
cases is censored the data are already
arranged in such a way that the smaller
survival time is at the top
and the largest at the bottom
now we create a second table which we
can use to draw the kaplan-meier curve
for this we look at which times occur in
this table and also add the time zero so
we have zero then
three four six seven eight eleven and
thirteen
in total we have ten participants
now we look at how many dental fillings
break out at which time
we enter this in the column m
so at time zero zero fillings have
broken out
after three years one filling has broken
out and after four years two fillings
have broken out
finally after six years one filling has
broken out
we now do this for all other time points
next we look at the number of cases that
have survived to that time
plus the cases where the event occurs at
the exact time
we enter this in the column n
so now n is the number of cases that
survived until that time
plus the people who drop out exactly at
that time
after 0 years we still have all 10
people
after 3 years we get 10 for n
nine people still have their feeling
healthy and one person has the feeling
broken out exactly after three years
the easiest way to get n is to calculate
the previous n value minus the previous
m value
so we get ten minus one which is equal
to nine
then nine minus two which is equal to
seven
seven minus one which is equal to 6 and
so on and so forth
from the column n we can now calculate
the survival rates
for this we simply divide the value n by
the total number in this case 10.
thus we get 10 by 10 which is equal to 1
9 by 10 which is equal to 0.9
7 by 10 is equal to 0.7
we now do the same for all others
now we can draw the kaplan-meier curve
at time 0 we have a value of 1
after 3 years we have a value of
0.9 or ninety percent
after four years we get 0.7
after six years 0.6 and so on
now we can plot these values
at zero we have one at 3 we have
0.9
at 4 we have 0.7 and at 6 we have 0.6
thus we can now read from the
kaplan-meier curve
what percentage of the filling has not
yet broken out after a certain time
but now we will still have to look at
the case when sensor data is available
for this i simply added sensor data in
these three places if you don't know
exactly what sensor data is feel free to
watch my introductory video on survival
time analysis
we now need to incorporate this data
into our table for the kaplan-meier
curve
so we create our m exactly the same way
as before we look at how many cases
failed at each time
now we add the column q
in the column q we enter how many cases
were censored at the respective time
it should be noted that the time at
which the respective censored case
occurred does not get its own row but it
is assigned to the previous time
let's take a look at this case
the censoring has taken place at time
nine
in this table however there is no time
point with nine years and it is also not
added
the respective subject is added at time
8.
now we can again calculate the values
for the survival time curve
if sensor data are available this is a
little more complicated
for this we write down these values in
the first step we get these values by
calculating n minus m
divided by n
so in this row for example we get with
12 minus 2
divided by 12 the value 10 divided by
12.
the calculation of the actual value is
done iteratively for this we multiply
the result from the previous row with
the calculated value
so in the first row we get 1.
now we calculate 12 divided by 13 times
1 which is equal to
0.923
in the next row we calculate 10 divided
by 12
times
0.923
and get a value of 0.769
we take this value again for the next
row
we now do this for all rows
afterwards we can draw our kepler-meyer
curve in the same way as before with
this data
now it could be the case that you have
two different materials for the filling
and you want to check if the material
has an influence on the survival time of
the filling
if you want to know how to do this
please watch my next video on the log
rank test
i hope you enjoyed the video and see you
next time
you